[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend der wahlkampf ist auf der
zielgeraden und noch nicht entschieden
die zeit ist knapp die abstände zwischen
den bewerbern sind es aber auch und das
ist eine situation in der selbst
kleinigkeiten die lage grundlegend
verändern können zb in einer debatte bei
der millionen zuschauen wie gerade eben
was war da die ausgangslage die
forschungsgruppe wahlen hat das im zdf
auftrag noch bis in den abend hinein
drei tage lang gemessen und ausgewertet
in einem allerletzten politbarometer vor
dieser spannendsten war seit langer zeit
matthias welche stimmungen haben die
demoskopen dagegen ist ja guten abend
klaus die letzte umfrage vor der wahl
die zeigt viel stabilität im vergleich
zur vorwoche der vorsprung der spd auf
die union verkleinert sich aber etwas
wenn heute schon bundestagswahl wäre
kämen cdu/csu auf 23 prozent plus 1 die
spd weiter auf 25 prozent hf g10 -1 fdp
fw linke 6 und grüne 16,5 prozent plus
ein halber punkt die freien wähler bei
drei prozent ab 3 prozent werden auch
kleinere parteien mit dargestellt und
die reihenfolge der parteien die wir
gerade gesehen haben die ergibt sich
übrigens aus dem ergebnis der letzten
bundestagswahl
als einziges zweierbündnis hätte eine
koalition aus spd und union jetzt eine
knappe mehrheit reichen würde es für
eine ampel aus spd grünen und fdp eine
regierung aus union grünen und fdp und
auch für rot grün rot die parteien die
jetzt gewählt werden entscheiden ja am
ende auch wer ins kanzleramt einzieht
wie sind da die sympathien mittlerweile
verteilt naja der vorsprung von olaf
scholz der bleibt deutlich das sehen wir
in dieser grafik armin laschet halten 67
prozent der befragten nicht für geeignet
als kanzler umgekehrt trauen das 64
prozent olaf scholz zu
annalena baerbock halten 69 prozent
nicht für geeignet
bei diesen werten überrascht es dann
nicht wenn die deutschen am liebsten als
bundeskanzler oder kanzlerin hätten
47 prozent wollen scholz im kanzleramt
sehen mit großem abstand vor laschet 20
prozent und baerbock 16 prozent also in
knapp 68 stunden schließen die
wahllokale
da müsste sich das alles sehr
stabilisiert haben wie festgelegt sind
die wähler wählerinnen jetzt heute haben
naja die wahlberechtigten die haben ja
noch drei tage lang zeit aus ihrer
wahlabsicht und nur danach kann die
forschungsgruppe wahlen ja fragen eine
wahlentscheidung zu machen und da kann
noch einiges passieren natürlich nicht
bei denen die schon briefwahl gemacht
haben und dieser anteil der wird
deutlich steigen ein drittel der
befragten ist sich auch gar nicht so
sicher ob und wenn dann wen sie wählen
wollen dazu kommt dass es immer weniger
feste bindungen an eine bestimmte partei
gibt das macht es den meinungsforschern
schwerer und es gibt immer statistische
fehlerbereich bei umfragen die umfrage
die wir gerade gesehen haben die ist
repräsentativ für die wahlberechtigte
bevölkerung in deutschland aber sie ist
keine prognose für das tatsächliche
wahlergebnis am sonntag das wollen wir
auch noch gar nicht wissen ist soll ja
eine überraschung sein spiel und toller
abend und ist angespannt dankeschön
matthias der gern die zahlen die
matthias gerade da vorgetragen hat
kannten die sieben in der schlussrunde
vorhin natürlich nicht aber sie haben
sich auch nicht groß verändert in den
letzten tagen sie wussten also alle was
sie vor sich hatten sehr wahrscheinlich
vor allem die letzte chance die dinge in
diesem wahlkampf noch mal in ihrem sinne
vor millionen menschen zu erklären
daniel putzen hat aus den letzten
anderthalb stunden besondere augenblicke
herausgeholt
vielleicht gab es nie so viel anspannung
und so viel politische ambition pro
quadratmeter fernsehstudio wie heute
abend das ging ja um vieles um sieg und
platz um die vermeidung von wahl-debakel
oder um all dies zugleich nicht zuletzt
ging es auch um unterstützung die
ausgangslage also delikat thema 1
gesellschaftliche spaltung
ein masken verweigerer erschießt einen
jungen kassierer in einer tankstelle
weil der ihn auf die korona regeln
hingewiesen hat dass auf den taten
folgen und die frage wie damit umzugehen
ist die
gesellschaftliche sorge die sich mit
diesem anschlag verbindet dass die
tonlage immer rauer wird und immer
aggressiver wird das ist etwas was wir
bekämpfen müssen und vor allem muss
jeder wissen der das macht er wirkt hier
auch auf die härte des rechtsstaats
treffen müssen die spd hier beim thema
online-durchsuchung bisher gespalten wie
würde ein kanzler scholz entscheiden es
sind ja mehrere gesetze für mehrere
sicherheitsbehörden für die meisten ist
es durchgekommen für die eine licht aber
das war etwas wo es ein streit gang und
bei andere fragen zwischen dem
innenminister den bundestagsfraktionen
und dem bundesrat ich selber hätte es
gut gefunden wenn das gesetz das die
bundesregierung auf den weg gebracht hat
auch was geworden wäre eine
distanzierung von der querdenker szene
hält die afg auch jetzt nicht für nötig
ich halte grundsätzlich nichts von
einer stigmatisierung einer
protestbewegung die sich im übrigen zu
großen teilen auch aus grünen spd cdu
wählern zusammensetzt das hat ja auch
eine erhebung ergeben dann thema wohnen
und bauen und enteignungen als letztes
mittel
erhaltungs frage im grundgesetz was
aufgabe von staatlichkeit ist und es
auch im grund gerechter auch ein letztes
mittel auch sie jetzt auch starts
richtung steht doch nicht drin
- womit das ein letztes mittel auch am
start zur verfügung steht für anderes
wichtiges instrument ist der mieten
decke und den fordern wir als linke
bundesweit wir brauchen deckel um die
mieter zu schützen damit eben die
geringverdiener aber auch die
normalverdiener nicht verdrängt werden
aus den innenstädten kategorisch dagegen
die fdp ebenso beim thema steuern gegen
das aufweichen der schuldenbremse das
ist nicht ratsam in der aktuellen
situation wir haben in deutschland ein
hohes defizit
wir sind sehr stark verschuldet in
europa wir haben inzwischen sogar
inflationsrisiken die wir beobachten ich
bin in sorge dass unsere europäische
zentralbank auch gehindert sein könnte
gegen die inflation zu arbeiten
zustimmung dazu von der csu
steuersenkungen statt steuererhöhungen
um nämlich die private wirtschaft und
das private engagement der menschen zu
stärken immer wenn steuern erhöht wendt
gibt es am ende weniger steuereinnahmen
und wirtschaftlichen misserfolg dann der
große schwerpunkt außen und
sicherheitspolitik ich möchte dafür
sorgen dass wir zu einer gemeinsamen
europäischen china politik kommen nicht
die 1 gegen die anderen ausgespielt
werden damit wir im wettstreit dieser
systeme als europa deutlich machen wir
haben eine eigene strategische
souveränität ich rate davon ab vor allem
im fall von der volksrepublik china mit
einer keule so wie es frau berbalk hier
gerade angesprochen hat
darüber zukommen denn volks die
volksrepublik china ist viel zu wichtig
geworden und jetzt auch noch viel
wichtiger in afghanistan und die
künftige rolle der bundeswehr
in afghanistan gerade erlebt 20 jahre
lang krieg 100000 zivile tote 12 5
milliarden euro hat die bundeswehr
einsatz gekostet jetzt die taliban
wieder da und sie sind stärker als je
zuvor die spd steht unabhängig davon zu
zusage bei den verteidigungsausgaben und
ich will gerne zu sagen dass wir im
rahmen der wirtschaftlichen
möglichkeiten auch in den nächsten
jahren weitere steigerung des
verteidigungshaushaltes brauchen nicht
dazu auch stehe dass das weiter so gehen
wird finaler schwerpunkt das klima und
hier bereits bekannte
schwerpunktsetzungen deshalb ist die
aufgabe deutschlands durch
spitzentechnologie eine freie
lebensweise wirtschaftliche perspektive
mit dem klimaschutz zu verbinden und die
nation der ingenieurin und techniker
kann dass teile aber ebenso diese
verzichts
verzichts gefühl nicht ich war ein
elektromobil das fahrzeug und das macht
spaß es ging hoch her zeitweise es war
spürbar das ist für viele um vieles für
manche um alles geht bis in rund 68
stunden die ersten zahlen da sind die
prognose am sonntagabend
und die uhr läuft wir haben einen
experten für politische kommunikation
von außerhalb gebeten diese anderthalb
stunden mit uns gemeinsam zu verfolgen
in österreich kennt ihn praktisch jeder
hier stellt man ihn besser vor professor
peter filzmaier ist der politik erklärer
schlechthin bei unseren nachbarn in der
anderen deutschsprachigen
bundesrepublik guten abend nach wie
den schönen guten abend nach deutschland
hätte man ja haben sie augenblicke
gesehen heute abend die nachhaltige
wirkung auf wähler haben könnten
angesichts dass wir ja einen
politbarometer gehört haben noch bis zu
ein drittel unentschlossen ist selbst
bei abzug nicht weil eine klar
zweistellige
millionenzahl von stimme noch gewinnbar
wäre aus meiner sicht überraschend wenig
bewegung drin ja es ging ein bisschen
hoch her es war aber auch phasenweise
mehr schlaf kampf als wahlkampf und zwar
deshalb weil niemand sich entschließen
konnte durchgängig die rolle des
angreifers einzunehmen das war bei olaf
scholz nicht zu erwarten das
auffälligste und dessen strategie ist er
sich betont unauffällig zu verhalten er
hat es 90 minuten geschafft keinen
einzigen anderen kandidaten persönlich
zu kritisieren oder für dessen sarg
positionen anzugreifen aber auch armin
laschet hat nur vereinzelt oder scholz
beim thema wohnen angegriffen ist
natürlich auch schwierig wenn seine
partei mit der spd also union und
sozialdemokraten gemeinsam regieren da
macht man sich ja auch selber schlecht
wenn man die regierungsarbeit schlecht
macht und was die oppositionsparteien
betrifft werden grüne fdp oder die linke
da stellt sich schon der verdacht dass
man darin hintertürchen für die
koalitionsverhandlungen offen lassen
wollte denn nach dem wahlsonntag ist vor
den verhandlungen wir haben ja alle das
gefühl dass er im moment im dramatischen
zeit blieben in der welt und in
deutschland und in österreich mit der
infrastruktur den politischen
verhältnissen warum ist es so verdammt
schwierig einen wahlkampf mit harten
kanten und mit feuer hin zu bekommen
denn dieses gefühl von schläfrigkeit hat
sich ja doch über die ganze zeit
hingezogen nicht nur in dieser debatte
das ist auch zumindest was die
kanzlerkandidat ihnen betrifft ein
selbstgemachtes problem denn die
wirklich große zukunft erzählung die
fehlt egal ob man das jetzt
zukunftsversprechen nennt oder auch
zentrale spins und kernbotschaften bei
der union war es ja lange zeit so dass
der eindruck entstanden ist haben
laschet glaubt er kann das kanzlei erbe
also eine art erbpacht antreten und
einfach mit buchhalterischer routine
sich den kanzlersessel ersetzen und das
funktioniert nicht hat man aber erst
sehr spät gemerkt der olaf scholz gibt
es zwar so etwas wie eine erzählung nur
die ist kurios dass als sozialdemokrat
sagt ich kann kanzlerin also erzählt die
geschichte ich bin die fortsetzung der
merkel jahre von jemand der in einer
anderen partei eben ist und bei den
grünen gibt es natürlich eine umwelt
erzählung aber auch da auch in der
diskussion zu merken scheut man sich
davor eine utopie wirklich zu ende und
vollständig zu erzählen inklusive der
dinge worauf müssen wir alles verzichten
da die lange liste wurde zumindest in
die erzählung nicht eingebunden und da
fehlt dann auch die polarisierung und
das was die feuer genannt haben nun kann
es ja feurig werden wir das tun geht aus
dem was die wähler jetzt am sonntag
entscheiden eine koalition zu schmieden
da werden sich höchstwahrscheinlich drei
parteien und wie einig werden sie haben
in österreich schon ausgesprochen
schräge koalitionen erlebt aus ihrer
erfahrung haus was steht den deutschen
nach dem sonntag abend bevor
deutschland hat es geschafft wenn auch
mit zeitverzögerung sich ihnen noch
komplexere und kompliziertere situation
hinein zu manövrieren denn was wir in
österreich keine ist wenn es mehrheiten
mitte rechts gibt konnten die nicht
realisiert werden weil mit sehr sehr
sehr rechten fpö keine beute und weil
diese sich auch noch mehrmals gespalten
hat das gilt teilweise natürlich auch
für die afd umgekehrt haben sie diese
gretchenfrage ist natürlich auch beim
spektrum links der mitte wie hält man es
denn nun mit der linken lässt man sich
von dieser dulden oder bezieht man sie
wieder auf länderebene geschehen auch in
eine koalition ein und das führt zur
situation dass wenn es sich ganz ganz
knapp rechnerisch doch ausgeben sollte
eine große koalition wider willen
entsteht das hat aber letztlich nur
andere parteien an dann geht stärkt das
wissen wir aus österreich oder man muss
drei experimente wagen aber dreier sind
dann oft nicht lotte 3 1 oder mühsam
dankeschön ich hoffe sie haben sich über
den abend doch wenigstens ein bisschen
als unser nachbar amüsiert danke nach
wien und am ende des tages ich bin da
stellt das heute-journal update dieser
letzten woche vor der wahl nach und nach
allen vertretern aller parteien noch mal
die dringendsten fragen heute abend
alles weidl von der afg und janine
wissler von der link und nun hier bei
uns beginnen die nachrichten mit einer
anderen debatte auf einer völlig anderen
bühne mit deutlichen worten hat
großbritanniens premier john cen in der
un-generaldebatte für mehr einsatz im
kampf gegen den klimawandel geworben die
erde dürfe nicht mehr wie ein
unzerstörbares spielzeug behandelt
werden sonst werde die weltbevölkerung
diesen wunderschönen planeten praktisch
unbewohnbar machen sagte johnson in new
york klimamaßnahmen würden auch den
volkswirtschaften nutzen johnson dankte
chinas staatspräsident hu jintao für
seine ankündigung keine kohlekraftwerke
mehr zu exportieren
über den globalen kampf gegen den hunger
beraten regierungsvertreter und experten
auf einem un-gipfel zur
ernährungssicherheit die pandemie und
der klimawandel verschärfen weltweit
hungerkrisen der norden kenias ist
besonders betroffen wassermangel und
dürren verschlechtern die
versorgungslage zusätzlich 800 millionen
menschen auf der welt haben nicht genug
zu essen so auch im süden madagaskars
die beseitigung des hungers ist eines
der wichtigsten nachhaltigkeitsziele der
un die bis 2030 erreicht werden sollen
zum abschluss der herbstvollversammlung
der katholischen bischöfe bilanzierte
deren vorsitzender bischof bätzing
uneinigkeit bei der aufarbeitung des
missbrauchsskandals
es liege noch ein langer weg vor der
katholischen kirche noch gebe es rund
1000 offene fälle im system der
anerkennungs leistungen beschlossen
wurde eine standardisierung der
personalakten in den bistümern auch die
diskussion der bischöfe über die
innerkirchlichen reformprozesses sei
intensiv und uneinig gewesen viele
gläubige reagierten enttäuscht
das von den gesundheitsministern
beschlossene aus für den lohnersatz von
ungeimpften in quarantäne zum november
stößt auf unterschiedliche reaktionen
kommunen und weltärztebund begrüßen die
entscheidung dagegen warnen
sozialverbände etwa vor einer
impfpflicht durch die hintertür die
ständige impfkommission hat zugleich
corona auffrischungsimpfungen für
immungeschwächte menschen empfohlen bei
den corona zahlen ist hervorzuheben dass
weitere 115 menschen an oder mit dem
virus gestorben sind so viele wie seit
drei monaten nicht mehr an einem tag
dagegen ist die sieben tage incidents
der neuinfektionen hierzulande erneut
gesunken laut rk ii auf
63,1
es ist noch nicht mal ein halbes jahr
her da zogen die usa in der pandemie
bekämpfung dem rest der welt auch
deutschlandweit davon schier
unerschöpfliche ströme von impfstoff
speisten ein massives militärisch
präzises nachschub system es gab bis zu
dreieinhalb millionen impfungen am tag
und irgendwann im sommer erstellte
dieser erfolgszug an einer wand aus
ideologischer sturheit die maske im
gesicht und hoch gerollte ärmel boden
den einen zur politischen statements um
den anderen zu objekten des hasses das
war dann ein bisschen so als hätte
charles darwin die menschheit und das
virus sind ein duell getrieben werden
twitter ist im kampf ums überleben und
die viren gewinnen dort gerade die
oberhand benjamin daniel berichtet aus
dem land unbegrenzter möglichkeiten
nicht unbegrenzte vernunft
[Musik]
wer an verschwörungs mythen glaubt wird
diese frau lieben eine ärztin die
behauptet dass corona virus sei nicht
tödlich impfstoffe hingegen
hochgefährlich und masken völlig nutzlos
mit diesen botschaften zieht diese
glühende trump anhängerin durch das land
verbreitet angst und falschinformationen
wenn eine ärztin inmitten einer pandemie
solche lügen verbreitet hat das zwei
verheerende folgen zum einen werden sich
gleichgesinnte darauf beziehen und sagen
schaut her das behaupten nicht nur bier
das ist mainstream 1 zum anderen
genießen ärzte generell großes vertrauen
in der gesellschaft
wie tödlich das corona virus tatsächlich
ist verdeutlicht unter anderem dieses
mehr an weißen fahnen auf der mall in
washington
jeder einzelne steht für einen menschen
der in amerika in verbindung mit dem
corona virus gestorben ist mittlerweile
liegt die zahl bei über
675.000 also mehr tote in den usa als
damals durch die spanische grippe trotz
dieser daten stagniert die quote der
vollständig geimpften in den usa bei
rund 55 prozent bei den us staaten liegt
über mont vorn mit knapp 70 prozent
schlusslicht ist west virginia dort sind
es gerade mal rund 40
neben bundesbeamten müssen sich bald
auch mitarbeiter privater unternehmen
mit mehr als 100 beschäftigten impfen
oder regelmäßig testen lassen und die
behörden geben grünes licht für booster
impfungen von älteren und risikogruppen
der us-präsident erhöht den druck aufs
eigene land blickt aber auch über die us
grenzen hinaus und spendet weitere 500
millionen impfstoff dosen für ärmere
länder natürlich nicht ganz
uneigennützig
die pandemie in den usa zu besiegen
müssen wir sie überall auf der welt
besiegen wir müssen unsere kräfte
bündeln bei drei wichtigen punkten wir
müssen das tempo der impfstoffproduktion
dramatisch steigern die dosen schnell
ausliefern und an den mann bringen
oder an die kinder in den usa rechnet
man in den nächsten wochen mit der note
zulassung des
impfstoffs für fünf- bis elfjährigen
laut einer umfrage ist allerdings nur
rund ein viertel der eltern entschlossen
ihre kinder auch impfen zu lassen
darüber hinaus zu kommen wird sehr sehr
schwierig werden der beiden regierung
bleibt wohl auch hier nichts anderes
übrig als weitere impfpflicht erlasse zu
beschließen
auch wenn es andere kräfte sind die
wider jede vernunft agieren wenn joe
biden aus seinem fenster blickt wird er
zur zeit ganz besonders daran erinnert
dass er am ende die verantwortung trägt
für das was gut läuft aber eben auch
alles andere
wir kommen zur
wirtschaftsberichterstattung und zu
einigen eigenartigen entwicklungen in
china dem marktplatz an dem die
westliche wirtschaft mittlerweile hängt
wie an einer rettungsleine im schatten
der korona krise und drastischer
maßnahmen wie wochenlanger quarantäne
für jeden reisenden geschäfts menschen
hat dort offenbar ganz generell eine
neue phase
systematischer abgrenzung begonnen
willkommen sind dann nur noch die die
für china unersetzbar sind alle anderen
werden immer mehr heraus gedrängt das
wäre gefährlich für unternehmen die vom
china-geschäft abhängen also sehr sehr
viele unternehmen gerade in deutschland
christiane hofmann berichtet aus pages
chinas wachstum schien unaufhaltsam
das land galt als zugpferd auch in der
pandemie hat das geschäft deutscher
konzerne stabilisiert doch zunehmend
stottert der motor der weltwirtschaft
der chinesische pragmatismus alles auf
wachstum zu setzen scheint vorbei die
politik lenkt in eine andere richtung
die größte sorge ist wohin die reise
geht wir wissen es nicht es gibt
wahnsinnig viele neue auflagen des china
koppelt sich von der welt wie krieg
unsere leute nicht mehr rein und es gibt
das problem will china jetzt noch
chinesisch sein wie weit sind wir
überhaupt noch einen faktor drin
auf 400 seiten analysiert die
europäische handelskammer die neue
politik vom ausland abkoppeln heißt es
nur noch know how soll ins land dass
china selbst nicht hat dem
maschinenbauer der chemischen industrie
oder halbleitertechnik ausländische
netzwerkausrüster oder telekom anbieter
sind nicht mehr willkommen
für china ist die unabhängigkeit in
einigen schlüsselbereichen eine frage
des überlebens
es geht nicht um effizienz sondern ums
überleben und
für präsident sie auch um den welt
machtanspruch im innern zieht erde weil
die zügel weiter an mehr regulierung
mehr kontrolle mehr statt kritik
verboten vom gemeinsamen wohlstand ist
jetzt die rede die kluft zwischen arm
und reich ist nach 40 jahren
sozialistischen turbo-kapitalismus wohl
zu groß geworden einige wenige seien
zuerst reich geworden erklärt herrn
version vom wirtschafts komitee jetzt
sollten sie den anderen helfen
aufzuholen die reichen die auch durch
und mit den mächtigen aufstiegen haben
verstanden vor allem die erfolgreichen
tech konzerne bekennen sich zur staat
und partei und spenden milliarden für
wohltätige zwecke und für die
entwicklung auf dem land alibaba 13 2
milliarden euro internet giganten sind
13,2 milliarden und elektronikhersteller
sony 1,9 milliarden euro doch damit
nicht genug der staat reguliert ganze
branche neu sichert sich den zugriff auf
die daten so sollen die unternehmen
verstärkt chinesische technik einsetzen
oft mit dem argument der nationalen
sicherheit
von unternehmen die in china bleiben
wollen entkoppeln ihre technologischen
und datenverbindungen von ihren globalen
aktivitäten es ist eine art
wirtschaftlicher festung die sich um
china bildet in der man drin sein kann
aber man ist nicht mehr so eng mit dem
mutterunternehmen zu hause verbunden
für die ausländischen unternehmen
bedeutet das höhere kosten und weniger
wachstum global im extremfall vielleicht
zwei getrennte wirtschaftskreisläufe
einen mit china und einen ohne
und es ist ein chinesischer
immobilienkonzern der seit tagen die
finanzmärkte beschäftigt eva brand ist
mit über 300 milliarden dollar hoch
verschuldet und hatte heute eine
millionenschwere zinszahlung zu leisten
valerie wie bewerten die experten die
schadens dimension dieses chinesischen
krisen konzerns eine weltweite
finanzkrise wie lehman brothers
ausgelöst hat die befürchten die
wenigsten dafür sind chinas banken zu
abgeschottet auch die deutsche
finanzaufsicht sieht für deutsche banken
keine gefahr aber eva gehört als rein
lokales problem zu sehen ist dann sicher
auch zu kurz gefasst dazu ist der
konzern einfach zu groß und die
immobilienwirtschaft in china zu
bedeutsam sie macht immerhin ein viertel
der chinesischen wirtschaftsleistung aus
verlassen sehen die baustellen von
evergreens projekten aus die arbeit
scheint zu ruhen beunruhigend für die
1,2 millionen menschen die noch auf die
schlüsselübergabe warten für wohnungen
die sie gegen vorkasse gekauft haben die
polizei steht schon bereit vor der
zentrale denn für neue nervosität sorgt
ein bericht im wall street journal
demnach bereitet peking die lokalen
behörden auf einen untergang und
mögliche unruhen vor viele sind von dem
immobilienentwickler abhängig 200.000
mitarbeiter hat eva grant und heuert
jedes jahr mehrere millionen arbeiter
für bauprojekte an außerdem schuldet der
immobilienentwickler hundert tausenden
kleinanlegern 6 milliarden dollar nach
eva grant könnten weitere
immobilienentwickler in die knie gehen
die chinesische immobilienblase
droht zu platzen
erst der internationale banken senken
ihre wachstumserwartungen für china das
wäre auch keine gute nachricht für
deutsche exporteure für die china einer
der wichtigsten handelspartner ist
vielen dank valerie nach frankfurt
seit jahren arbeitet die eu kommission
an einheitlichen standards für ladekabel
und buchsen von smartphones und anderen
elektronischen geräten jetzt hat die
behörde einen gesetzentwurf vorgelegt
mit dem ziel der vereinheitlichung um
kosten und elektro schrott zu reduzieren
nach zustimmung von eu parlament und
ministerrat sowie einer übergangsfrist
ist frühestens ende 2024 mit einem
einheitlichen ladekabel zu rechnen
der afg
bundestagsabgeordnete axel gercke ist im
alter von 79 jahren gestorben
der arzt und hochschulprofessor war bis
zu einer erkrankung im herbst 2009 10
gesundheitspolitischer sprecher der fdp
fraktion
der vulkan auf la palma spuckt weiter
lava und asche immer mehr anwohner
müssen sich in sicherheit bringen etwa
350 häuser wurden bisher durch das
flüssige gestein zerstört unterdessen
ist das spanische königspaar auf der
insel angekommen um sich ein bild von
den schäden zu machen und den
betroffenen trost zu spenden
da sich die fließgeschwindigkeit der
lava erheblich verlangsamt hat
befürchten fachleute dass sie sich
weiter ausbreitet und immer mehr
zerstört zudem drohten den
inselbewohnern weiterhin gefahr durch
giftige gase und asche wolken
das war es nun von uns quasi am
eingangstor für politisch hoch
aufgeladene wochenendtage bis
sonntagabend und möglicherweise geht es
ja da erst richtig los in die richtung
was blüht uns dann steuert gleich auch
die debatte bei maybrit illner diesmal
nicht mit politikern sondern wir
menschen die kritisch verfolgen was
politiker tun und was sie sagen und
alles was dazwischen liegt bleiben sie
da ja und um 0.30 bindet wulf schmiese
in unserem heute journal update noch
einmal alles zusammen
[Musik]
genannt kerstin tim und uwe das sind die
drei hochs und tiefs sie uns derzeit
beschäftigen das hoch kerstin hat
inzwischen schon zwei zentren und das
kleine tief über die iberischen
halbinsel drängt die so ein bisschen
auseinander
dieses tief tim ein kleines sturmtief
erreicht morgen früh bereits das
baltikum und das tiefe ziehen daher
erreicht aber norwegen und lässt uns im
wesentlichen in ruhe sie sehen dass es
gibt nur geringe luftdruck gegensätze in
deutschland also eher ruhiges wetter
heute nacht pfeift der wind noch an der
ostsee und in norddeutschland kann es
hier und da auch noch mal leicht
tröpfeln im süden ist es dagegen klar
und dort sinken die temperaturen unter
dem klaren sternenhimmel also auf 10 bis
6 grad unter den dichteren wolken bleibt
es bei 14 bis 10 grad milder und morgen
erwarten uns dann höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 16 grad an der ostsee und 24
grad am oberrhein und in norddeutschland
ist es doch meistens stark bewölkt
selten zeigt sich die sonne bei westwind
im süden dagegen gibt es zum teil
strahlenden sonnenschein hier vom
berchtesgadener land über das allgäu bis
zum oberrhein und am samstag ändert sich
an dieser wetterlage noch wenig da kommt
allerdings die sonne in norddeutschland
auch häufiger zum zuge und die
temperaturen steigen auf 16 bis 26 grad
der sonntag wird dann spannend denn von
südwesten kommen schauer und gewitter
heran die bis zum montag auch den norden
und nordosten erreichen guten abend